el fentanilo es un fármaco opiáceo
sintético se receta para tratar el dolor
intenso Generalmente causado por el
cáncer o una cirugía
también existe una forma ilícita que se
fabrica y se vende ilegalmente en el
mercado de la droga
la gente la toma porque produce un
fuerte subidón e intensas sensaciones de
bienestar
es hasta 50 veces más potente que la
heroína un opioide ilegal y 100 veces
más potente que la morfina o tropioide
usado para tratar el dolor
como con cualquier opioide la adicción
al fentanilo es una enfermedad
neurológica en la que se tiene un deseo
abrumador de consumir el fármaco usted
no puede dejar de tomar el medicamento a
pesar del daño que pueda causarle si
usted es adicto y deja de tomar el
fármaco puede sentirse mal este malestar
se llama abstinencia
un tratamiento importante para la
adicción a los opioides como el
fentanilo es el tratamiento asistido con
medicamentos o mat el mat es un abordaje
integral del paciente que combina la
medicación para ayudarlo a dejar de
consumir opioides con orientación y
terapia conductual tres medicamentos que
se usan para tratar la adicción a los
opioides entre ellos el fentanilo son la
metadona la buprenorfina y la naltrexona
en el cerebro cada droga se adhiere a
los mismos receptores de las células que
el fentanilo
la metadona activa los receptores pero
es una droga de acción más lenta que el
fentanilo porque tarda más en llegar al
cerebro cuando se utiliza según los
recetado
esto reduce la sensación de subidón y
evita los síntomas de abstinencia
la buprenorfina es un fármaco más débil
que el fentanilo porque no activa los
receptores de manera tan marcada Esto
hace que sea mucho menos probable que
provoca una sobredosis que un fármaco
que activa totalmente los receptores
también bloquea la adhesión del
fentanilo a los receptores así reduce
las ansias molestas de consumir
fentanilo sin causar la sensación de su
bidón
la naltrexona bloquea los receptores
opioides adhiriéndose a ellos para que
el fentanilo no pueda hacerlo esto evita
que el fentanilo le provoque un subidón
reduce el deseo pero no detiene los
síntomas de abstinencia
el tratamiento farmacológico es más
eficaz cuando se combina con la terapia
conductual la terapia ayuda a manejar el
estrés y las situaciones que pueden
desencadenar el deseo de consumir
fentanilo la sobredosis de fentanilo es
decir Tomar demasiada cantidad de este
fármaco puede provocar síntomas
potencialmente mortales una sobredosis
de fentanilo puede ralentizar o detener
la respiración
así la falta de oxígeno puede provocar
un coma daño cerebrales permanentes e
incluso la muerte llama inmediatamente
al 911 si cree que se ha producido una
sobredosis de fentanilo inicia la rcp si
la persona no respira o no tiene pulso
el tratamiento más eficaz y que
salvavidas en caso de sobredosis es la
naloxona es un fármaco inyectable o un
aerosol nasal que bloquea rápidamente
los efectos del fentanilo y puede
detener una sobredosis de opioides Para
más información sobre el tratamiento de
la adicción y la sobredosis de fentanilo
hable con su médico para más fuentes de
información u otros lugares donde
recibir ayuda consulte los enlaces en la
descripción a continuación
[Música]